most polls show like in your research as
well that people feel like they're less
free than ever and it's concerning
because we're that's how what makes this
country great hi I'm Nicolas reason TV
and today we're talking with one of the
cofounders of Lincoln labs Aaron Jin
he's one of the people putting on the
reboot 2014 conference Aaron thanks for
talking to us thanks for coming Nick
tell us about the Lincoln labs project
what is Lincoln knives and what are you
hoping to accomplish with it Leland
started out of a need we saw in the
market was that there are lots of people
like myself we were part of the
conservative libertarian movement and
we're not organized and after the 2012
disaster we decided all that you know
there's there was myself there was
Garrett and Chris like well we exist so
other of us people must exist as well
and we also kind of got sick and tired
of people saying that everyone our age
everyone is millennial everyone in tech
was like you know progressive and they
you know might as well go to become a
communist and it didn't really make
sense either to the valley because the
valley was so entrepreneurial so I
engaged in helping consumers and so we
started the project we originally
started as a meet-up do we we met up at
a bar in menlo park called Oasis we were
expecting a small turn on the 30 people
ended up being over 100 and then we held
another one San Francisco over 100 then
we held our first hackathon over 250
people showed up and the movement
started growing and growing and people
were interested in liberty ideas and a
lot of people in technology meaning to
feel like you don't have a home anywhere
and so you I've been like elapsed helps
provide a home for people who are
conservative or libertarian or
interested in something other than a
kind of doctrinaire left-wing political
agenda yeah they basically don't like
what's spewed out by most people who are
very successful in tech and like you
know going and helping the progressive
movement so talk about a reboot what's
you know what's the function of the
conference and how will you know if
you've succeeded we picked the tunnel
because want people look excited again
who or who believe in Liberty and like
you know we had a little bit of a
slacking over the core
28 years both in the sense of policy and
also in the sense of you know are we
actually making traction in the public
eye I mean this is in terms of the
Republican Party no Justin just in
general like like I think I think people
so see the two but I think it goes one
way but elson doesn't go the other way
like I think if if Liberty if we're
educating people more about what we
actually believe about like why we
believe and free markets why we believe
in entrepreneurship I think like at
least that standing like most polls show
like in your research as well that
people feel like they're less free than
ever and it's concerning because we're
that's how what makes this country great
run is all of us like not the government
so reboot so it's a conference that
pulls together conservatives and
libertarians they're being called
conservatorium conservatory ins yeah and
you know what is the what's the large
team of reboot and do you think it's
working it's been a year and since we
started leaking lab so this is like our
animal annual and ors our anniversary
and I think it's gone pretty well maybe
we've reached over 13,000 people last
year and we pull together this
conference in tune F months and we had
we sold out on Monday we actually turn
people away from who are coming at the
door yesterday and so I think that
people are I think people really
interested i think is I think the
movement is going forward I think people
in technology community now are like
more or less coming out of the closet
that they they may actually not want the
government involved in every part of
their life what is the attraction of
what you guys are talking about
Millennials could I think that that
perspective I mean we're all Millennials
who started started this is that we're
in that camp like we're not partisan
most of us not like like yeah like I
vote Republican and I am a Republican
but if anyone goes into Google's my name
they will see my open criticism of lots
of things we do and I think that
represents what technology has sort of
brought about in society which
assistance of transparency in
authenticity and a desire to just fix
things like make things work and sort of
leave us alone like Millennials it's in
your pole like Millennials are almost a
very similar to technology entrepreneurs
they're almost like ruthless Republicans
is capitalist who who don't like welfare
states and want to determine their own
direction but they but they also apply
that to their private lives they really
want to be private they don't want the
government to be evolved a lot of that
stuff so I think that Lincoln labs hits
on that same point of like we're totally
willing to work with people on the other
side we like on education reform
immigration reform and we're we're not
really interested in partisan bickering
like if if Rokon khanna's run it in in
santa clara against honda you know once
they come to our events great like we
agree on a lot of issues and I think
that's what people are looking at let's
week we'll walk from our democracy now
is they want people to fix things and
like leave us alone right all right well
that sounds great we'll leave it there
thank you aaron jen co-founder of
Lincoln labs and one of the main
organizers of the reboot confidence
thanks thanks thanks for talking to
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie